hello everyone and yes welcome back to
the good stuff it's 1921 World
Championship match between Xhosa roll
Capablanca and Emmanuel asper we already
see we'll already seen four games
all four were ended in a draw and here
we have game five which might also have
ended in a row but it could also be a
very crazy game with a decisive result
there's no way to tell unless we watch
the video so without further ado let's
just check it out kappa blanka for the
third time with the white pieces now
opens with the d for the first time he
opened with d4 then he tried a four and
we had a nice rule opus now again he
goes for d4 Lasker continues with d5
with Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and now
c4 and of course II 6 and the Queen's
Gambit the client is on the board Bishop
to g5 Capablanca doesn't like the
closest bishop in with III before
developing it with 9b d7 and only now
III with Bishop to e7 by Lasker Knight
to c3 and Lasker castles to safety
we have rook to c1 by capablanca b6 and
now C capture Sun b 5e capture Sun d5
and Queen to a4 and here c5 and this is
where the game basically starts
Capablanca says that up until this point
c5 was considered to be the strongest
move here and capablanca agrees that to
the c5 is the strongest move here but he
said it here he had an inspiration and
then that he found and the only idea
that that basically challenges this c5
move and here he played Queen to c6 now
what's the plan here obviously if this
was good people would have spotted it
before now the rook is under attack so
what do you do here
Lasker played rook to b8 of course you
have to get the rook out of harm's way
and now you have to decide what's next
Bishop to f4 looks like an excellent
move your attacking the rook here the
rook doesn't really have a good square
to go to and but the problem is you can
go brush up the b7 and now Queen to a4
yes your rook is still under attack and
now you can either move the rook to a8
which defends the a7 pawn but you can
also go rook to c8 and this is why black
says yes sure grab my pawn I'm gonna
grab some activity now you cannot trap
the Queen here because the bishop is
hanging so first bush of the c6 and
now how do you get the Queen back into
the game if black is allowed to push c4
and lock the light square Bishop out of
the game it's gonna be very good for
black so here Bishop to b5
but now Luke the a 8 Queen to c7 and
only now Bishop captures on b5 and after
Knight captures you will now eliminate
da to pawn so you win your pawn back and
you have a much better position for
example if we get a queen trade over
here rook captures and you have to
defend the pawn ruby 1 then you get c4
and at one point and black will kick
away this night start pushing B 5 B 4 C
3 maybe create a passed pawn on the
Queen side and black will have a very
nice game so this is definitely not what
capablanca had in mind what's the idea
behind Queen to c6 well here come on cap
late night capture Sun d5 and ok Lasker
continues in the same fashion Bishop the
b7 first tries to kick away the Queen
and then if this is possible a white
loses a piece so Knight capture sunny
summon with Czech Queen captures on e7
and now you have to get the Queen out of
the way Queen to a4 so what's what's to
be played here rook beat the c8 my
Lasker now what do you how do you
continue here would Wike you already
grabbed a pawn can you grab another for
example Queen captures on a7 the
question is no because here after you
capture on before the you I mean the
Queen and the king are on the same file
so you will not be able to recapture and
even if Roe character since e8 first
then the Queen to b4 check white loses
castling privileges King D 1 and now
you'll capture with the bishop so the
bishop on b7 doesn't remain a target
everything is nicely defended and black
just has a better position
so after rook beat the c8 capablanca
says this is the position he had in mind
when he decided to go for this Queen to
c6 idea Queen to a3 and now he says that
now we're ready to develop our light
square Bishop which goes to a6
Capablanca wants to dominate the Queen
side then he castles safety and black is
unable to untangle here because the
Queen on e7 is undefended
so this is the the pin we're talking
about here at last brown pins we have
Queen to e6 and now you can go Bishop to
a6 immediately because first a couple of
anchor says you need to capture on f6 if
you play Bishop basics right away then
black can go captures a
before there's still this tension going
on here if you capture rook captures
here you will have to Castle kingside
but then again you will be able to now
capture on f3 and perhaps give up the
exchange but all in all you don't really
get all that much so after Queen t6
first Bishop characters now the Queen
has to move away you cannot capture with
the night as the knight has to keep on
keep an eye on the c5 pawn so Queen
captures on f6 and only now butter up to
a six and here this moves 16 by kappa
blanka you all know the time control in
this match is 15 moves per hour so here
Lasker took more than half an hour for
his next move which is pretty crazy
because you have to play 15 moves an
hour so taking more than half an hour
for one move means that you are left
with a less than half an hour for your
next 14 moves but it is a big decision
here if you don't do something you're
just worse for example if you play
something like this - of character
screen captures you're gonna have a lot
a lot of problems on the Queen side that
Bishop on b7 really was a monster Bishop
for example if rook c7 defending the
pawn you just Castle and now rook F to
c8 yes you have nicely doubled your
rooks on the C file but who Brooke FD 1
and you don't have a good way of
reacting to this tension in this century
you will never be able to capture here
because of this Queen captures on c8
with check rook captures rook captures
you just give up two rooks for a queen
and after a night here tonight chapters
on d4 and this is just a dominant
position for white yes you you are only
up one pawn but you have two rooks for
the Queen and the black will not be able
to do anything pretty much here it will
be a slow and painful death for black so
after Bishop days 6 Lasker decides to to
give up the exchange Bishop captures on
f3 he gives up the exchange here and see
it and Capablanca says that this is the
absolute best way to play this would
black and if you know an ordinary mortal
was playing this position he might have
gone for something different but Alaska
knows his stuff and he decides you know
activity above all so capablanca accepts
the challenge with Bishop cat person c8
rook a person c8 and now G captures an
f3 Queen captures on f3 by Alaska are
now attacking the
on each one look the g1 getting row card
we also pressuring the the Jeep on here
and now rook to e8 already asking
Capablanca or you may be up for a draw
if maybe capablanca captures an a7 then
last working sacrifice on e3 and after
captures captures you will play King you
want and now you can either play series
of checks Queen need to reach a queen
III check Queen f3 check back and forth
with a with a draw or you can capture on
g1 with check deliver another check
maybe get the knight back to safety you
know create some squares for the King
and then you will be you will be fine
not right away I excellently I
accidentally play that move so after
loop to e8 capablanca plays Queen to d3
I'm nice centralizing move with the
Queen keeping an eye on the d4 pawn also
may be preparing Queen T the Queen to be
one or or Queen to eat it to maybe offer
a queen trade here g6 by Lasker and now
there are two ways to go about it you
can either unpin for example go King f1
or try rubgy 3 for example Queen h1
check Queen to f1 but then the Queen
just retreats Queen to e4 again you're
threatening the capture here and the
White Queen is somewhat misplaced
so after g6 with King to f1 by kappa
blanka and now rook to e4 with the
pretty simple threat see capture sorry
see capture son d4 is the threat as the
Queen is undefended here and here we
have Queen to d1 now as the king is no
longer on e 1 black doesn't have any
tricks with rook captures only 3 kappa
blanka offers a queen trade of course
last 4 declines Queen h3 check with rook
to g2 now defending the h2 pawn and
Knight to f6 now last 4 wants to get
this night over to h5 capture on d4 and
then bring the knight over to f4 to
create some threats against the rockin
g2
so kink the g1 again kappa blanka on
pins and seek a purse on d4 and here
what do you play here here capablanca
says that if you just continue captures
here then Knight 285 really is a problem
because you have to prevent Knight to f4
if you don't it's just game over for
white so you're you're probably gonna go
Queen C to attack the rook Queen to f3
and then what do you play again you have
to stop
therefore you have to play queen d-104 a
queen trade black will just repeat queen
to h3 Quinta c2 and we have a drop by
repetition for example
so after C capture Sun before this is
the move cup of Blanca head of mine and
he says if I didn't have this I don't
know what what else to play rook the c4
now he's asking would you play here last
core of course captures on e3 but here's
the deal
capablanca now captures on e4 and it's
actually not great to capture on f2 it
seems like a such a nice in-between move
you know you're you might be thinking
okay it's a sufficient cook time but
it's really not for example if you
capture here then you freed the rook to
to control the F file rook captures an
f2 and only now if you recapture Queen
d8 check King g7 and now Queen to d4
check checks the King wins the night if
you didn't capture on after the rook
would still be on g2 and you would have
Knight back to f6 this is the idea so
here at Lasker doesn't have a way to
further improve he just has to capture
the rook with Knight captures rook and
now comes Queen to d8 check King to d7
and now Queen to d4 check and now couple
unka is able to force the knight back
Knight to f6 now it's possible of course
and only now F captures on e3 a couple
Blanc is not only one point but he's up
the exchange and he's ready to play rook
to f2 to put some pressure on the knight
on f6 quintessence by Lasker it's time
to you know pull back as you are no
longer attacking now you are defending
rook to f2 and now you you constantly
have to keep your queen and king here
otherwise you're just gonna lose the
material last pair plays the g5 he wants
to get his king over to g6 the unpin we
have h4 by kappa blanka and this is now
move 31 so another set of 15 moves has
been played now you have more time an
additional hour for the next 15 moves
and here we have G captures on h4 by
Lasker this is the move that was sealed
so here the game was adjourned and
continued later Capablanca says that
probably better was king g6 and then if
H captor Sun g5 and 94 now you're
threatening Queen to g4 check and then
you will be able to harass the white
king and the Queen is no longer
controlling this the squares here so
after Queen d3 pinning them
queen g4 check you're gonna go King to
g2 that's all erupt - G - but now Queen
to f3 and it's hard to say who is who's
better here or whose works
Lasker did not like him to g6 he said
nope G captures on h4 is better with
Queen captures on h4 by kappa blanka and
now Knight to g4 which is not a problem
the knight is actually a beautiful piece
here capablanca doesn't have an F pawn
or an H point to her as the night so you
will just play something like f5 or h5
and the night will be a monster night on
g4 basically so what do you do here if
you try something like rook g2 which
seems like something you want to do you
lose the e3 pawn Queen captures on e3
and now what do you play King f1 you're
gonna go get h5 and the night is just
beautiful there you cannot capture on h5
because you get Queen to f3 check and
now you either move from the rook and
lose the rook or you go King the g1 and
then in d1 is just mate in one
so whatever you do doesn't work here so
after 90 G for a couple Annika plays
Queen to g5 check and now King to f8 and
here a cup of one cup late
rook to f5 later after the game
capablanca mentioned that rook to d2 was
probably better because roof to d8 is
such a terrible threat there's really
not much to do here you have to play f6
as the knight guards d f6 square it's
okay but then after Queen to f4
what again what do you play for example
you either play h5 and then after h5
Queen to d6 trades Queen's which is
favorable for white and if you don't
play h5 you play something like King to
f7 then again just rook the d6 attack
the Queen and after Queen to c8 now you
play E for and your position is just
great and blacks blacks pieces aren't
doing all that much now the Queen has to
keep an eye on the night here which is a
pretty passive thing to do you can't
really deliver any checks well you can
you can deliver Queen c5 check but it's
not a problem King G to the king will be
very safe there
the queen is guarding the C ones who
will not be able to deliver any jerks
there but okay I mean that that was
found in home analysis in the game
Capablanca played
rook to f5 and here he says Alaska has
some chances Alaska doesn't like Queen
captures on e3 where you can just trade
on into the same game where
down the exchange but still Europe
dewpoints so but but Lassiter doesn't
like his chances here instead he plays
h5 and now we have Queen to d8 to check
by kappa blanka we have a some
repetition here at King g7 Queen g5
check King to f8 Queen to d8 check King
to g7 and Queen to g5 check with King to
f8 not really sure if this was already a
three-fold repetition I'm not sure if
threefold repetition existed back then
back then you probably just repeated
moves and then you know you nodded your
head and the players agree to a draw but
I don't think if it was a specific rule
I don't know when this rule will became
official of a three-fold repetition I
read somewhere that before it wasn't so
much of a three-fold repetition as it is
today where the position is just
repeated three times I think back then
when it was the rule was first
introduced you it would have to be the
repetition of moves such as in this case
repeating a queen here Queen here but
not for example if you repeated a
position several times and then play
something else and then the position
again repeated itself I don't think it
was the case back then but if any of you
have some you know nice resource where
we can brush up our vast knowledge on
this you know feel free to share in the
comments about ok what do you play here
here Capablanca played b3 which is not
the most precise way the best idea was
Queen to f4 we're capturing an e2 is
really not an issue here if you capture
on a2 then you get Queen to d6 checked
and now black is lost if you go
somewhere here then Ruby g5 is deadly if
you go here then you get rook to d5 with
the threat of checkmate so you can't
really prevent mate any check will be
met with just rook to d1 if Queen
delivers check and if you try f6 then
you're just getting made it Queenie sex
check King to f8 and now you can play
whatever let's say Ruby da to check
picks up the Queen so even that is
enough I better get after King f8
Capablanca played b3 he didn't find the
the the Queen f4 move which also defends
da to pawn indirectly but now Queen d6
buy last four last score now wants Queen
to g3 couple on
of course denies it we have Queen to f4
block / curse queen and now Queen to d1
check with Queen to f1 and now Queen
back to d7 again think I'm defending the
pawn here you can't really move your
queen a lot as the rook is also under
attack but Capablanca now wins the h5
pawn
okay last four wins the e3 pawn a nice
trade off and now Queen to f3 pressuring
the night and there aren't all that many
squares for the night the Queen and rook
guard this square the Queen and regard
this square the c4 pawn guards this
square you don't really want to go back
with the knight King or blacks case
forward
so Queen to d4 just defending the knight
and threatening some nasty discoveries
here capablanca plate into a to check
with King Teti 7 and now you don't want
to capture here if you capture then just
King e6 and you don't really have any
good checks rookie 6 check you get f6
and you're done with checks now it's
blacks turn to do some nasty discoveries
so couple longer goes Queen to b7 check
and now what do you play here here you
you have to play King to b6 and now
white we'll just have to settle for a
draw after a repetition of moves here
Queen B a check when b7 check or if you
try rook age 6 check here you're gonna
get f6 and after Queen b8 check King e6
and there are no good ways to continue
this if you try something from behind
Queen a5 King f5 and again you don't
have to moves any move that's not a
check a black will respond with a with a
deadly discovery and then it's black was
on the attack so this is what Alaska had
in mind when he thought about this and
remember after Queen b7 I checked this
is a couple Blancas 45th move and a last
curtain now has to make his 45th move to
reach the 4th time control so they
already finished their three sets of 15
moves per hour so Alaska has to make one
more move and here
Lasker played King to f8 here the quote
above the board says I had a quarter of
an hour to think but it was absolutely
incapable of doing so this is what
Lasker says about this position so he
had 15 more minutes but he didn't really
spend them wisely he played King to have
faith but King to f8 is actually a
blunder that loses the game for Lasker
unfortunately for last group who really
played a stunning game here
a beautiful exchange sacrifice and
really there's so much attacking
potential but this doesn't work last car
didn't you see is 15 minutes but you are
welcome to use a few seconds pause the
video and try to find the winning idea
for kappa blanka here I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
have just defeated Emmanuel Lasker for
the first time in your life and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the movies Queen to be a trip not
going to see it or queen today it seems
similar but it's really not I'm gonna
explain Quinta be it check wins the game
this what couple Blanca played and this
is where Emmanuel Lasker resigned the
game for the first time against clozaril
capablanca and Cabo Blanco got his first
victory over a dr. emmanuel asked her he
resigned because here whatever you play
loses if you try King to g7 then it's
just Queen tha check into g6 and you
don't even have to capture the Queen
just win to h8 is mate
the King has nowhere to go and the
problem is well it's not actually a
problem the the beauty of the position
is what happens after king to e7
the point is why I said you can't play
Queen to see a check or Queen to a check
because you have to keep an eye on the
e5 square now you get looked if I've
checked this resource would not be
available to you if you try to Queen to
see it or Queen to a a check and now
what do you play here if King to f6 then
it's not a problem just the Queen to h8
check King to g6 and now rook the g5
check a nice
sacrifice of the rook after the King
captures you just eliminate the Queen
and now it's game over and on the other
hand after rook e5 check if you don't go
to f6 if you go King to d7 it's also not
not possible Queen captures an a7 came
to d6 and now Queen to e7 check King to
c6 and now Queen to f6 check you get the
same thing if you move the King anywhere
for example King here just rook check
picks up the Queen here and if you block
with the Queen then the problem is at
the knight on e3 is no longer defended
it just captures captures and not that
sorry not that rook captures on e3 and
you get what I think young Gustav son
often mentioned that his favorite end
games are the ones where he has a rock
and his
bounine doesn't so here we have one such
endgame of course completely winning for
white but yeah last but of course all
this end after Capablanca played queen
to b8 check Lasker just resigned which
is really a terrible terrible thing I
mean last for this is the fifth game of
the match Lasker really played the
previous four games brilliantly and here
he played brilliantly like like he was
twice as youngest couple monk or not you
know or older than him
and I mean really really such a shame to
ruin a game like this but time ctrl+ you
know probably he was tired he couldn't
have been too tired as the game was
adjourned and then continued but who
knows how we're gonna continue this
match and see what happens and what
Lasker had to say about this game some
other games and you know the match in
general so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Patrick
pagoda James chambers Doug McNabb hey
Suz dahveed Badillo Herrera and Donald
Pettingill for a contribution to my
channel thank you what I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
on my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga checking
up in our suggestions and continuing
what we are currently doing thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day